ragazzi sono veramente un fonico parlare
di reali che cosa è successo nel bisogno
di oggi di among us ragazzi perché ho
ucciso a fine partita l'impostore io ero
impostore senza sapere che fosse
impostore per sapere di cosa sto
parlando
guardatevi vi giuro non è un kit di
giuro che non entri gbyte guardate visto
video per favore che incredibile buona
visione
[Musica]
allora ragazzi o due veri subito 1697
come si fa che noia deve morire
secondo me i ragazzi questa qua non è
facile perché che noia se la giocherà
molto agguerrita sempre lei il problema
alla single mamma la ricordo intensiva e
gas
ho trovato la formazione sul rosso
disco rosso ma perché è riportato
trovarci ma io riporto riportato io ho
pagato chi come non sei marce sì adesso
invece che sono molto ma non mi ha
ucciso nel chelsea non ha solennemente
che non mi ha ucciso nessuno
io riporto al canale del rosso e rovi e
il rosso è morta che mario maiolo la
ragazza dai bellissimi cominciare questa
partita bellissima
non succede io so solo che non ha capito
nulla rami sono andata in caffetteria ho
trovato il corpo viola ho detto è morto
uno qua report non è morto e quindi per
me è tutto a posto
però il report non l'ho fatto io l'ho
fatto march come posso fatto il ragazzo
era marcia in a morte in store ed è che
siete gioca andato giochi diversi
anch'io e mi vado anch'io
diamo adesso se qualcuno è morto
[Musica]
non si sa bene questa cosa ma non ora
che non ho capito si è capito un cacchio
prova bel chissenefrega
ma veramente io non ho mai visto una
cosa quando la prima volta che mi
succede a roba del genere però vabbè
allora sabotaggio due giovani sono due
vediamo che riusciamo a beccare che
succede adesso chiamo rai a 3 giu stiamo
allora sono entrato in delle case chiuse
la vuoi fare a parlare aspetta le porte
di security erano chiuse mi si siano
aperte sono entrata speciali in security
e non c'era nidi morto quindi
probabilmente chi l'ha ucciso ha preso
dance ed io sotto incrociato sì infatti
ma niente era con noi magari il killer
l'ha uccisa ha chiuso le porte così che
mi avete votato comunque non sarà gara
adesso apparire strano è strano matri
riceve detto che era potevo votare parti
che pirla
se votavo buddy andava bene perché lo
buttavano fuori uno in meno mannaggia al
cacchio va bene allora vediamo di fare
un paio di tasche utili non è vero sono
l'impostore che pascolava io mi ammazzo
che noi ha costituito in versi insomma
visto uscire nessuno in security
perfetto
bhatti è nel mezzo bardi e marci sono
fermi ok forse muoiono perché non fanno
in tempo oxygen
61 fatto perfetto l'ho dovuto fare io
sono lo facevano i ragazzi meno male se
non mi prendevano perché dicevano è
perché non lo styling e perché non lo
facevi perché sono un impostore
ovviamente però voi non lo sapete che in
via praga per chi è lui a cagà allora
secondo me sono charlie e cesko anche
secondo me non serve anche secondo me ma
fermi si chiede chi lo ha fatto meglio
di voi due ha fatto sei così ti dico sì
sì sì sì march margini dico solo questo
ossigeno l'ho fatto io penso non
morivano tutti ti dico di sì devo
consumer ossigeno e chi di voi due l'ha
fatto quindi se non io io esca affatto
ossigeno voi due reti quanto ossigeno
ho fatto io ossigeno charlie raga ma
sbaglia ragazzi e cesca perché esagerata
ma stavo facendo legge non lo stavo
facendo
ciao
si no
all'inizio allora ragazza è successo è
una cosa vogliate bene se avete
legislativa
lasciatele è da vedere whatsapp per
favore ma cosa ma a mardin e li faccio
non so mai impostore mi metto le a
[Risate]
quando si vedrà che la spinta giuro non
si pensava succedesse supergirl va bene
siamo i dottori della feste vediamo di
riuscire a fare una roba in admin e
decente ragazzo liti partino poi avverrà
nei 60 sì o sì ok
certo che può averla sono io che sono un
babbo allora ragazzi mi raccomando tutto
no no che noi non tutti a far le tasche
perché se no non è un senso al mega
all'inizio siamo tutti qua in zona
quindi spero veramente che non ci sia
niente di strano tra trento e uno
particolato ascheri emergenti come ho
sbagliato chi è il politico nero o nero
i radio allora io ero in electrical aree
siamo arrivati ha mangiati in due anni
chi sa quanto provando lo hanno visto
niente io avevo messo l'aifa da caricare
perché ci sembra più carica allora cosa
anche quello che dico io
among us ma il video in salvo darren
electrical siamo entrati io è single ma
perchè sti po tesi e ben fatti ha visto
uniti enit impersonando mi sembra vanità
per me la cipolla perché è spiato troppo
frega di quello che è successo a juve
non è mica ce la possa fare sto a fare
affari sto blog di me due ore di upload
manco quando caricavo i video su youtube
nel 2001 che non c'era youtube
comunque se tutti si impegnassero a fare
le tasche con impegno io vinceremo tutti
solo per le tasche
mistici sta seguendo facevano troppa
gente che non mi piace la cosa non mi
piace di chi sta seguendo troppa gente
la cosa non mi piace non mi piace
nichi stasera allora affiniamo seta
scolo definiamo seta sono maledizione
finiamo se task quanta gente io so che
se questo non è il posto migliore dove
stare
sorry c'era da emergency da fare quindi
metto quattro ragazzi non so chi sia la
task i computer l'abbia vinto facciamo
le merci al cambiamento abbia vinto a ok
possibile tassa come però è bene sarai
avversari communication cominciarle come
impossibile perché io ho visto morire
davanti a me
charlie e c'erano single moment ricerca
nero contatti raga perché lo sono
benevento
e allora o sei tu e single ma io non lo
so ma so che c'è sky brava mentire
single ma non lo conosco asta che cesca
non mentire
gli sci stata una gradita è velocissimo
ammazzano tutti via da tutti ma non a
lei arriva lui ho continuato a correre
una grimana la scopa creativa a lei
ragazzi questo nome non lo sapete
proprio va bene io ho finito da due ore
le mie tasche gli altri ovviamente non
fanno mai ma c'è qualche tutti facessero
pole maledettissime task noi a quest'ora
avremmo vinto
ma la gente le tasche non le fa
fate l'amore spinge quindi anni chi era
è incredibile parte
porca miseria alcuni ragazzi questa era
era il vino si diverte tantissimo
giocatori tutti che ve lo dico
mi sono divertito un sacco probabili sia
piaciuto come si deve creare e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo vino e ragazzi
[Musica]